يا رفاق، هذا يعطيكم فكرة عما
يمكن أن يبدو عليه 700 بوصة من الثلوج المتساقطة في موسم واحد، وهي
محطة للحافلات
أقف فيها ولكن ألقوا نظرة على كمية
الثلوج الموجودة حولنا والتي يبلغ ارتفاعها حوالي 60
قدمًا من الثلوج  لقد تساقطت هنا
أكبر كمية من الثلوج التي رأوها هنا في
جبل ماموث في شهر مارس،
وهي الآن رقم قياسي لكمية الثلوج
التي شاهدوها هنا متجاوزة
رقمهم القياسي القديم منذ عام 2020. ولكن ما عليك سوى إلقاء
نظرة على مكان تساقط الثلوج  علامة التوقف، هل كانت
هذه مجرد كمية لا يمكن فهمها
من الثلوج التي رأيناها في
كاليفورنيا في موسم الأمطار هذا
وكان رائعًا بالنسبة للجفاف الذي رصدته الولايات المتحدة
مع أرقام جديدة
اليوم، حيث يعاني واحد بالمائة فقط من الولاية
من جفاف شديد الآن  لأن لدينا
الكثير من الأمطار هنا وهذا يعني
أن هذا المنتجع هنا في ماموث
سيكون قادرًا على البقاء مفتوحًا حتى نهاية
شهر يوليو، فهم يقولون فقط لإعطائك
فكرة ولكن انظر هنا فقط لإظهار
ما يحدث لك مرة أخرى  يبدو أن مقدار
تساقط الثلوج هو أمر لا يصدق
بالنسبة لك